alright this is a candy crush soda saga
level 60 walkthrough with some
commentary I'm going to kind of place in
the beginning part fast just because
it's a level to take some time but
basically making the level or making a
video right now because you know this is
a frustrating level that lucky pup
trouble with and i wrote a guide a while
back that explains the strategy and some
people get frustrated I get a lot of
negative late of comments you know stuff
that people say when they're frustrated
like it's all luck and things like that
and it really isn't so I wanted to show
that if you follow the tips and the
guide that you can actually beat this
level faster than if you just randomly
do whatever and hope to get lucky no
reason I said you know I'm playing fast
in the beginning is because really
there's not a lot of options and what
you want to do is just clear out this
middle spot here you know the middle of
the board so you just try to find the
best matches that it will help you
accomplish that you'll see that I'm not
really going after the bears at the
bottom just like I say on the guide you
know that clearing out the middle will
actually make that possible later so you
know we want to do this first and you
know I think this is probably the eighth
time you know I tried so I don't want
you to think that you can read the tips
and follow them and invito on your first
try so this is where things get kind of
interesting
we're down to eight moves and it looks
pretty hopeless at the time you know
because we hadn't had the middle opened
up so we weren't really giving MUC much
in the way of cascades but you can see
that now that we have popped it open a
little bit that all of a sudden things
are moving the way we want and then just
in those like last two moves here we
have really made some progress on
clearing out the top of the board so you
can see that we never really went after
popping the bottles at all just like you
know like I say in the guide you know
that happens kind of organically as you
go and with these last five moves we're
going to want to try to make some
specials so that we can get a cascade up
to get that last bear out you know you
see like I'm not I'm not working towards
him I'm not trying to make matches next
to him what I'm trying to do instead is
just get the pieces to move up and
slowly but surely they start to chip
away at those blockers because there's
too many blockers you can't do it you
can't do it the other way and you know
by setting off that striped candy there
we got all of them all the other bears
to pop and then he popped out for us and
now we can just match this wrapped candy
right here and there you go so you know
one of the things that you want to
definitely keep keep hanging in there it
you know it we were down to eight moves
it doesn't look good but by following
that method of just getting things to
cascade up we got all the bear's loose
in there finish the level so always hang
in there always just keep plugging away
at the middle read the rest of our tips
for some more ideas about how to
approach it and if you keep doing that
like I said I think this was my eighth
try so you won't do it every time but
you will get it eventually and sooner or
later you'll pass the level and you
forget all about it so hope you hope
this helps up you can get past it
yourself leave a comment if you have any
questions please like the video found it
helpful and visit our site candy crush
soda saga tips com if you need help with
anything we have a guide that will
probably help you figure it out alright
thanks